This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Medellin, Colombia is set in the middle of a steep valley of green mountains with a river running through the middle. In this busy city of about 4 million people, the weather is perfect, averaging about 72 degrees Fahrenheit year-round. We call it La Ciudad de la Eterna Primavera, the city of eternal spring. It's both urban and forested, and it's just a beautiful place. I spent some of my childhood there.
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马尔斯。哥伦比亚的麦德林坐落在绿树成荫的陡峭山谷中间，一条河流从中穿过。在这座拥有约 400 万人口的繁华城市里，气候宜人，全年平均温度在 72 华氏度左右。我们称它为“永恒春天的城市”。它既有都市风情，又环绕着森林，是一个美丽的地方。我的童年有一段时间就是在那里度过的。
That's producer Luis Gallo. I remember afternoons at my aunt's apartment, way up in the hills of Menejin. She teached my cousin, my brother and me how to paint. And from her windows, I could see the whole city. The high-rise towers dotting the forested valley. I can still smell the air. A mix of pine and balsa trees. And damp soil. So unique to this part of the world that I haven't smelted anywhere else. But as beautiful as the city was when Luis was a kid, back in the 1980s, Medellin was
那是制作人路易斯·加略。我还记得在阿姨公寓里度过的下午，那座公寓位于麦德林的山区高处。她教我和堂弟、还有我弟弟画画。从她的窗户望出去，我能看到整个城市。高层塔楼点缀着长满森林的山谷。我至今还能闻到那种空气。松木、轻木和潮湿泥土的混合气味。这种气味是这个地区独有的，我在其他任何地方都没有闻到过。但正如路易斯小时候这座城市那么美丽一样，在 20 世纪 80 年代，麦德林
also in the middle of a full-blown crisis. 30 years ago, this was the murder capital of the world. Today in Medellin, military police were patrolling the streets looking for bombers. That's largely because of Pablo Escobar's notorious Medellin Cartel, which waged a bloody drug war right on the city's streets. 13 bombs have gone off in Medellin since the weekend. The city's mayor today signed an order imposing a 10 p.m. to dawn curfew in the city. At the time, my father was a captain in the counter-narcotics unit for Colombia's national
同时也处于全面危机的中心。30 年前，这里是世界的谋杀之都。今天在麦德林，宪兵正在街头巡逻寻找炸弹客。这在很大程度上是因为巴勃罗·埃斯科瓦尔臭名昭著的麦德林卡特尔，他们在城市街道上发动了一场血腥的毒品战争。自周末以来，麦德林已经发生了 13 起炸弹爆炸事件。该市市长今天签署了一项命令，在全市实施晚上 10 点到黎明的宵禁。当时，我的父亲是哥伦比亚国家警察缉毒部门的一名队长。
police. He was basically fighting the narcos. I remember one day when our family was leaving the city and my dad was driving our SUV, we were suddenly attacked and shot at. My mom, brother, and I had to duck under the seats as my father sped away. Escobar had declared war on the Colombian state.
他基本上是在与毒贩作战。我记得有一天，我们一家人正要离开这座城市，我爸爸开着我们的 SUV，我们突然遭到袭击和枪击。我妈妈、弟弟和我不得不躲在座椅下面，而我父亲则加速驶离。埃斯科瓦尔已经向哥伦比亚国家宣战。
My family eventually decided to leave the country, and we moved to the US. For Medellin's residents, the threat of random deadly shootings and bombings was real and constant. To outsiders, the city became synonymous with the cocaine war and indiscriminate violence. But then, in its darkest hour, Medellin began to find its way out of that crisis.
我的家人最终决定离开这个国家，我们搬到了美国。对于麦德林的居民来说，遭遇随机致命枪击和爆炸的威胁是真实而持续的。对外人来说，这座城市成了可卡因战争和无差别暴力的代名词。但随后，在它最黑暗的时刻，麦德林开始寻找摆脱这场危机的方法。
I did a story a few years ago for this show about a sweeping revival program Medellin launched in the mid-1990s. As part of that plan, the city built parks and libraries and public spaces. Medellin's leaders also invested in poor neighborhoods, locally known as comunas. Community programs were created for residents who had long been neglected. The sweeping program was called social urbanism, a term coined by city leaders. It was designed to breathe new life into Medellin by investing in the needs of city residents. And it seemed to work.
几年前，我为这个节目做过一篇报道，讲的是麦德林在 20 世纪 90 年代中期发起的一项全面复兴计划。作为该计划的一部分，这座城市修建了公园、图书馆和公共空间。麦德林领导人还对当地称为科穆纳（comunas）的贫困社区进行了投资。为长期遭到忽视的居民创建了社区项目。这项全面的计划被称为社会城市主义，这是城市领导人创造的一个术语。它旨在通过投资城市居民的需求，为麦德林注入新的活力。而且它似乎奏效了。
Social urbanism, along with a harder focus by police on drug trafficking, helped the city's murder rate plummet by at least 80%. Against incredible odds, Medellin transformed from a notoriously violent narco capital to a more peaceful model city. The press called it the Medellin Miracle. Today, celebrities who could live anywhere in the world have chosen to stay in Medellin, their hometown. That includes reggaeton stars like J Balvin. It's a city inside of the mountains, you know, it's a lot of nature around. You just gotta go. I guarantee that you'll be back
社会城市主义，加上警方对毒品贩运的更严厉打击，帮助该市的谋杀率暴跌了至少 80%。在难以想象的逆境中，麦德林从一个臭名昭著的暴力毒品之都蜕变成了一个更加和平的模范城市。媒体称之为“麦德林奇迹”。如今，世界上任何地方都能安家的名人们都选择留在他们的家乡麦德林。其中包括雷鬼巨星雷鬼歌手 J·巴尔文。这是一个位于群山之中的城市，你知道的，周围有大量的自然风光。你必须去看看。我向你保证，你会回来的
2000% if not I give you your money back. 2020, I decided to move back to Medellin. I rented an apartment that I really liked from a friend in El Poblado, not far from where my family had once lived. And now, I was close to all the best bars and restaurants. Walking around, I sensed a city overflowing with creativity. I discovered hip new design shops, a listening bar where DJs played vinyl records every night, and my favorite cafe where I often did work. Medellin was buzzing. It really felt like the place to be. But soon after I moved back, I started talking to other people in the city,
百分之二千，如果不回来我把钱退给你。2020 年，我决定搬回麦德林。我从埃尔波夫拉多（El Poblado）的一个朋友那里租了一套我很喜欢的公寓，离我家人曾经住过的地方不远。现在，我离所有最好的酒吧和餐厅都很近。走在街上，我能感觉到这座城市洋溢着创造力。我发现了新潮的设计店、一个每晚都有 DJ 播放黑胶唱片的听音酒吧，还有我经常去工作的最喜欢的咖啡馆。麦德林充满活力。这感觉真的是个好去处。但自我搬回来后不久，我开始与城里的其他人交谈，
and it became clear to me that Medellin is in trouble again. Because in the last few years, there's been an explosion of new problems, like huge spikes in housing costs, the widespread displacement of locals, and worse. Many residents are now worried that the so-called Medellin Miracle is crumbling, and they fear that their city is at another breaking point. But before we get to the story of this latest crisis, a quick reminder of what things were like when the Medellín Miracle first started back in the mid-1990s. At the time, residents were filled with hope about the future of their city, thanks to the new revival program.
我清楚地意识到麦德林又陷入麻烦了。因为在过去几年里，新问题呈爆炸式增长，比如住房成本飙升、当地人大规模流离失所，以及更糟糕的情况。许多居民现在担心所谓的“麦德林奇迹”正在崩溃，他们害怕自己的城市正处于另一个崩溃点。但在我们讲述最新危机的这个故事之前，先简单回顾一下 20 世纪 90 年代中期“麦德林奇迹”刚开始时的情况。当时，由于有了新的复兴计划，居民们对城市的未来充满了希望。
People were especially excited about their brand new public transportation system. excited about their brand new public transportation system. The Medellin Metro first opened in 1995. I remember the TV ads with aerial shots overlooking downtown showing the brand new trains with green and gold stripes speeding in and out of stations. I was eight years old when we went as a family to ride it for the first time. My cousin, brother, and even my grandma came. I remember looking out the train's window, almost floating over the city,
人们对他们全新的公共交通系统感到特别兴奋。对他们全新的公共交通系统感到兴奋。麦德林地铁于 1995 年首次开通。我记得电视上的广告，航拍镜头俯瞰着市中心，展示着带有绿金条纹的全新列车在车站进进出出。我们全家第一次去坐地铁时我八岁。我的堂弟、弟弟，甚至我奶奶都去了。我记得看着火车窗外，几乎是在城市上空漂浮，
and getting a panoramic view of Medellín's skyline. I was obsessed. I think a lot of people in Medellin felt this way. It was the first metro system in the whole country. It was proof that things could change. And maybe those really scary times were over. Medellin's residents began feeling that same wave of optimism as the city came up with even more creative solutions to its transportation problems. The city built a massive series of outdoor escalators
并获得了麦德林天际线的全景。我着迷了。我想麦德林很多人都有这种感觉。这是整个国家的第一个地铁系统。这是事情可以改变的证明。也许那些真正可怕的时代已经结束了。随着这座城市为其交通问题提出更多富有创意的解决方案，麦德林的居民开始感受到同样的乐观浪潮。这座城市建造了一系列巨大的户外自动扶梯，
that stretches to nearly 330 feet up into the foothills. It was created primarily as transportation for commuters in the working class hillside neighborhood called Comuna 13. The city also added more metro stations and cable cars going up into the comunas. Luis Fernando Gonzalez is a professor of architecture at Columbia's National University. He says that metro broke down barriers and social segregation and it's one of the main symbols of the city's revival. Neighborhoods all over Medellin were now linked by a web of trains, streetcars, and buses stretching across the city. The
一直延伸到近 330 英尺高的山麓。它主要是为了给被称为第 13 公社（Comuna 13）的工人阶级山坡社区的通勤者提供交通工具而建造的。该市还增设了更多地铁站和通往各个公社的缆车。路易斯·费尔南多·冈萨雷斯是哥伦比亚国立大学的建筑学教授。他说，地铁打破了屏障和社交隔离，是城市复兴的主要象征之一。麦德林各地的社区现在通过横跨城市的火车、有轨电车和公共汽车网络连接在一起。这个
transit system became the crown jewel of the Medellin miracle and a model for cities around the world. It helped make the city a star in international urban planning circles. Academics and politicians flocked to Medellin to learn how they got it so right. And as the city's profile rose, Medellin's leaders saw a huge opportunity. In 2003, a handsome, charismatic mathematician and professor named Sergio Fajardo was elected mayor. Inspired by Medellín's revival, he and other leaders decided to go even bigger. The dream of Medellín was to insert itself into the globalization of the administration. Luis Fernando says Medellín's dream was to become a global city.
交通系统成为麦德林奇迹的皇冠明珠，也是世界各地城市的榜样。它帮助这座城市成为了国际城市规划界的明星。学者和政治家蜂拥至麦德林，学习他们是如何把事情做得如此完美的。随着这座城市的知名度上升，麦德林的领导人看到了一个巨大的机遇。2003 年，一位英俊、富有个人魅力的数学家兼教授塞尔吉奥·法哈多（Sergio Fajardo）当选市长。受麦德林复兴的启发，他和 其他领导人决定把格局打开。麦德林的梦想是将自己融入行政的全球化进程中。路易斯·费尔南多说，麦德林的梦想是成为一个全球城市。
To Fajardo and his team, that meant more than just a world-class transit system and social urbanism projects for locals. He wanted to put Medellín on the map as the most educated, most respected, most talked about city in all of Latin America. Fajardo figured that the best way to make his city a player on the regional stage was to promote Medellín as a tourist destination. Tony Puig, who is one of the sellers of Marca Ciudad and City Marketing, as it was called. Luis Fernando says Fajardo hired a man named Tony Puig, who was an expert at marketing cities.
对法哈多和他的团队来说，这意味着的不仅仅是世界级的交通系统和当地人的社会城市主义项目。他希望将麦德林打造成为拉丁美洲教育程度最高、最受尊重、最多人谈论的城市，从而将其推上地图。法哈多认为，让他的城市在地区舞台上崭露头角的最快方法，就是将麦德林推广为旅游目的地。托尼·普伊格（Tony Puig）是“城市品牌”（Marca Ciudad）和城市营销（City Marketing）的推销员之一，正如当时所称的那样。路易斯·费尔南多说，法哈多聘请了一位名叫托尼·普伊格的人，他是城市营销专家。
He'd once created a tourism campaign for Barcelona, which had done its own huge infrastructure overhaul ahead of the 1992 Olympics. His campaign was very successful, which Fernando calls it the Catalonian miracle. The Catalonian miracle sold Barcelona's transformation and attracted millions of visitors. Fajardo's team copied and pasted the Barcelona model with no criticism to Medellín. Huyg's marketing team created beautiful books showcasing Medellín's new libraries and parks and cable cars flying above the comunas.
他曾为巴塞罗那创建了一个旅游推广活动，该市在 1992 年奥运会前进行了巨大基础设施改造。他的活动非常成功，费尔南多称之为加泰罗尼亚奇迹。加泰罗尼亚奇迹推销了巴塞罗那的转型，并吸引了数百万游客。法哈多的团队将巴塞罗那模式直接复制粘贴到了麦德林，没有任何批评。普伊格的营销团队制作了精美的书籍，展示了麦德林的新图书馆、公园以及在公社上空飞驰的缆车。
Every aspect of the new Medellín got a museum exhibition, a press release, or a photo spread. Social urbanism now had a look. There's a joke in Colombia that paisas, as the people from Medellin are known, are the best salespeople, because they can talk you into buying anything. And Medellin's leaders sold a new vision of the city. The campaign takes Medellin in a new direction that sells the city is going from fearful to hopeful. Fajardo's PR team flaunted the city's miraculous revival and in terms of impressing the world, the publicity campaign worked perfectly. By the mid-2000s, not long after the campaign started, Medellin was
新麦德林的方方面面都办了博物馆展览、新闻发布会或照片专版。社会城市主义现在有了视觉形象。哥伦比亚有个笑话，说 paisas（麦德林人的称呼）是最好的推销员，因为他们能说服你买下任何东西。麦德林的领导人们推销了这座城市的新愿景。这场运动将麦德林带向了一个新的方向，将这座城市推销为从恐惧走向充满希望。法哈多的公关团队大肆宣扬这座城市奇迹般的复兴，就惊艳世界而言，这场宣传活动取得了完美的效果。到 20 世纪 2000 年代中期，也就是活动开始后不久，麦德林
quickly becoming one of the hottest tourist destinations in the world. The New York Times ran a glowing article in its travel section explaining why everyone should go and bask in Medellin's quote-unquote Renaissance. Anthony Bourdain visited Medellin, ate arepas in Bandeja Paisa, and rode one of the cable cars. So even a few years ago, it would have been unthinkable to come up here? Oh, completely. And during Escobar times, this area used to be called the Assassin's Cradle. That was then, this is now. Over the next decade and a half, Medellin was put on all sorts of lists of must-see
迅速成为世界上最热门的旅游目的地之一。《纽约时报》在其旅游版面发表了一篇热情洋溢的文章，解释了为什么每个人都应该去沐浴在麦德林所谓的“文艺复兴”之中。安东尼·波登访问了麦德林，吃了烤肉饼（arepas）和安蒂奥基亚拼盘（Bandeja Paisa），并乘坐了其中一辆缆车。所以即使在几年前，来这里也是不可想象的？哦，完全是。在埃斯科瓦尔时代，这个地区曾被称为刺客摇篮。那是过去，这是现在。在接下来的十五年里，麦德林被列入了各种必看城市名单中。
cities. In 2022, nearly a million and a half people visited Medellin. When this tourism boom first started, Colombians were excited. We wanted people to come and see that Colombia was different from what they saw in movies and TV shows. In a sense, Fajardo's PR campaign had worked on us too. If so many people were coming, it must be a sign that we were doing something right. We believed the hype. But looking back, something was off. Those glossy books, all that international promotion of the city. At a time when Medellín was still supposed
2022 年，近 150 万人访问了麦德林。当这场旅游热潮刚开始时，哥伦比亚人很兴奋。我们希望人们来看看，哥伦比亚与他们在电影和电视节目中看到的有所不同。从某种意义上说，法哈多的公关活动对我们也有用。如果有这么多人来，那一定表明我们做对了什么。我们相信了这场宣传。但回想起来，有些不对劲。那些光鲜亮丽的书籍，所有对这座城市的国际宣传。在麦德林本应
to be focused on rebuilding for its residents, the city seemed to be putting so much energy into attracting foreigners. And then those visitors came and stayed, which the city wasn't ready for, and that is having huge ramifications throughout Medellín. In Provenza, a main pedestrian strip in the posh neighborhood of El Poblado, streets are crowded most days of the week with locals and foreigners. People drink and dine next to creeks lined with lush green mosteras that grow like weeds throughout the city. One day, I noticed large posters plastered on walls next to the shops and restaurants. Today I noticed large posters plastered on walls next to the shops and restaurants. One reads, in bold black capital letters, Medellín is not for sale.
专注于为居民重建的时候，这座城市似乎把太多的精力投入到了吸引外国人上。然后那些游客来了并住了下来，这是这座城市没有准备好的，这正在整个麦德林产生巨大的连锁反应。在普罗文扎（Provenza），高级社区埃尔波夫拉多（El Poblado）的主要步行街上，一周中的大部分日子里，街道上都挤满了当地人和外国人。人们在绿意盎然的龟背竹（长得像杂草一样遍布城市）环绕的小溪旁喝酒用餐。有一天，我注意到商店和餐厅旁边的大街墙壁上贴着巨大的海报。今天我注意到商店和餐厅旁边的大街墙壁上贴着巨大海报。其中一张用醒目的黑色大写字母写着：麦德林不出售。
Stop gentrification. There's another one, with a megaphone shouting, gentrifiers, go home. Ana Valle is the artist and activist behind the posters. She was born and raised in Medellin and comes from a family of human rights advocates. Ana says that when she was growing up in the 1990s, she rarely saw non-Columbians in Medellin. That's because its image around the world was that of a very dangerous city. But then a few years ago she noticed her own neighborhood was changing. She's been seeing many more foreigners at the grocery store, in her gym, and in her building. Not just tourists or visitors,
停止士绅化。还有一张，上面画着一个拿着扩音器大喊的扩音器，上面写着：士绅化者，回家吧。安娜·瓦莱（Ana Valle）是这些海报背后的艺术家和活动家。她在麦德林出生长大，来自一个有人权倡导者背景的家庭。安娜说，当她在 20 世纪 90 年代长大时，她很少在麦德林看到非哥伦比亚人。那是因为它在世界上的形象是一个非常危险的城市。但几年后，她注意到自己的社区正在发生变化。她开始在杂货店、健身房和自己的大楼里看到越来越多的外国人。不仅仅是游客或访客，
but people staying for good. good. Ana says this influx of foreigners has caused many locals to feel … literally, that means a general nuisance, or annoyance. That may seem small, but Ana's protest posters show how she and other locals are grappling with something pretty huge. The knock-on effects of foreigners staying and meddling long term. What ever posters really stood out to me. There's a drawing of a Christopher Columbus style ship.
而是长住下来的人。安娜说，外国人的涌入让许多当地人感到……字面意思是，这是一种普遍的滋扰或烦恼。这可能看起来很小，但安娜的抗议海报显示了她和其他当地人如何应对一件相当大的事情。外国人长期停留和干预产生的连锁反应。确实有一张海报让我印象深刻。上面画着一艘克里斯托弗·哥伦布风格的船。
And in giant block letters it says, Digital Nomads are temporary colonizers. There has been an explosion of digital nomadism over the last several years, thanks to the rise of remote work. Those who can travel freely and work from any place where there's internet have fanned out two beautiful cities and towns around the world.
巨大的醒目字体写着：“数字游民是临时殖民者”。由于远程工作的兴起，过去几年数字游民呈爆炸式增长。那些能够自由旅行并在任何有网络的地方工作的人，已经分散到世界各地美丽城镇。
Many of them have chosen Medellin, where their vacations can start as soon as they log off. TikTok is filled with videos of nomads, mostly young white Americans and Europeans, telling their peers why they should come and stay long term. Medellin, Colombia allows you to set up your life in such an amazing way. There's a YouTube video posted in late 2023 by a nomad named Pablo, giving advice to other foreigners about how to settle in the city. Some people come for a couple weeks. I wanted to go for one or two months, and then I ended up staying for five months.
他们中的许多人选择了麦德林，在这里，他们的假期一关掉电脑就可以开始。TikTok 上充满了游民的视频，主要是年轻的白人美国人和欧洲人，告诉他们的同龄人为什么他们应该来这里长住。哥伦比亚麦德林让你能以如此惊人的方式建立生活。2023 年底，一个名叫巴勃罗的游民发布了一段 YouTube 视频，就如何在城市安居向其他外国人提供建议。有些人来几周。我想去一两个月，结果呆了五个月。
And then I came right back. I wanted to talk to some digital nomads myself, and I knew exactly where I could find them. I made my way to a WeWork in the heart of Poblado, not far from where Ana put up her posters. The scene looks like any other co-working space like Brooklyn or Berlin. Digital marketers, programmers, and tech workers crowd communal tables while sipping their cold brew. English is the main language spoken into headsets and airpods. I asked one of the guys sitting next to me what made him decide to come to Medellin. I just fell in love with the city. Medellin is super green.
然后我又回来了。我自己也想和一些数字游民谈谈，而且我知道在哪里能找到他们。我来到了波夫拉多市中心的一个 WeWork，离安娜贴海报的地方不远。这里的场景看起来就像布鲁克林或柏林的任何其他联合办公空间一样。数字营销人员、程序员和科技工作者挤在公共桌子旁，啜饮着冷萃咖啡。英语是耳机和 AirPods 里交流的主要语言。我问坐在我旁边的一个小伙子是什么让他决定来麦德林的。我只是爱上了这座城市。麦德林超级绿。
I think the culture is really, really unique and cool. Hampton Rees is a blonde Texan in his early 30s. He lives in El Poblado, an upper middle class district of 400,000 people south of downtown. Foreigners love El Poblado. They call it the Beverly Hills of Medellin. It's the epicenter of nightlife, shopping, and entertainment, with boutique hotels rising above treetops. Rainbow-colored macaws add to Poblado's lush tropical vibe.
我认为这里的文化真的很独特很酷。汉普顿·里斯（Hampton Rees）是一名 30 岁出头的金发德州人。他住在埃尔波夫拉多，这是一个位于市中心以南、拥有 40 万人口的中产阶级高档区。外国人喜欢埃尔波夫拉多。他们称之为麦德林的比弗利山庄。这里是夜生活、购物和娱乐的中心，精品酒店拔地而起，高过树梢。彩虹色的金刚鹦鹉为波夫拉多的郁郁葱葱的热带氛围增添了色彩。
Hampton also thinks that a big draw for foreigners is the neighborhood's party scene. You hear a lot that there's beautiful women, so I think you see a lot. I have at least seen a lot more male digital nomads than I have seen female digital nomads. They can go to clubs and buy bottles, and they can go to really nice restaurants,
汉普顿还认为，吸引外国人的一个重要原因是该社区的派对场景。你经常听到那里有美女，所以我想你确实看到了很多。我至少看到过比女数字游民多得多的男数字游民。他们可以去俱乐部买酒，还可以去非常高档的餐厅，
things that they might not be able to do in the U.S. Hampton is staying in Colombia on what is known as a digital nomad visa. Colombia introduced the visa in 2022. Those who can prove they're employed remotely can work in the country for up to two years. Nearly 60 countries offer some version of the digital nomad visa. It took Hampton less than two weeks to get his. Nomads were already making their way to Medellin before Colombia started issuing the special visa. But since then, there's been a noticeable spike in foreign arrivals in the city. The floodgates opened up. Out of the nearly one and a half million people who visited Medellin in 2022,
这些事情他们在美国可能做不到。汉普顿持所谓的“数字游民签证”在哥伦比亚居留。哥伦比亚于 2022 年推出了这种签证。能够证明自己远程就业的人可以在该国工作长达两年。近 60 个国家提供了某种版本的数字游民签证。汉普顿花了两周不到的时间就拿到了签证。在哥伦比亚开始发放这种特殊签证之前，游民们就已经在前往麦德林的路上。但从那以后，该市的外国游客数量明显激增。闸门打开了。在 2022 年访问麦德林的近 150 万人中，
roughly 100,000 were digital nomads who stayed long term. Every year this number grows, breaking the record from the year before. And most of those newcomers are Americans. In his YouTube video, Pablo steers those nomads to places like El Poblado. Yes, this is a third world country, but if you live in these areas, like I'm telling you, you can still experience a really high end quality lifestyle. Nomads love to talk about how cheap life in the city is. There's this idea that in Medellin they can enjoy a kind of luxury
大约有 10 万是长期居留的数字游民。这个数字每年都在增长，打破了前一年的纪录。而且这些新来者大多是美国人。在视频中，巴勃罗将这些游民引导到像埃尔波夫拉多这样的地方。是的，这是第三世界国家，但如果你住在这些地方，就像我告诉你的那样，你依然可以体验到非常高端的生活品质。游民们喜欢谈论这座城市的生活有多便宜。有一种观点认为，在麦德林他们可以享受一种
they couldn't afford in the US or Europe. And that is a huge draw. You're going to probably spend around $2,000 on a nice place, particularly in Empolalo, the Beverly Hills of Medellin. huge draw. This is a YouTube video from 2023 with two guys, one Australian, one from the US. It's called Why Everyone is Moving to Medellin. But the reality is, for most Colombians, these things are not cheap. And the nomads are setting off a major housing shortage in the city. There is a crisis of rents, a crisis of housing, some major problems. Luis Fernando says there is a rental affordability crisis, and it's one of the main problems
他们在美国或欧洲负担不起的奢华。这是一个巨大的吸引力。在埃尔波夫拉多（麦德林的比弗利山庄），你可能会花大约 2000 美元买一个好地方。巨大吸引力。这是一段 2023 年的 YouTube 视频，里面有两个小伙子，一个来自澳大利亚，一个来自美国。它被称为《为什么每个人都在搬到麦德林》。但现实是，对大多数哥伦比亚人来说，这些东西并不便宜。而且游民们正在该市引发严重的住房短缺。存在租赁危机、住房危机，还有一些重大问题。路易斯·费尔南多说，存在租金负担能力危机，这是
with the arrival of digital nomads. 8,700 digital nomads arrive every month, leaving millions of dollars. Luis Fernando says 8,700 digital nomads are coming to Medellín every month. Although they inject millions of dollars into the economy, they also cost the rising rents, housing costs, and the displacement of residents. Apartments that would typically be available to locals are now rented out to tourists and digital nomads, and this housing shortage has hit our reporter, Luis Gallo, close to home. A few months ago, my landlord told me he could be getting way more money for my apartment in El Poblado.
数字游民到来带来的主要问题之一。每月有 8700 名数字游民到来，留下了数百万美元。路易斯·费尔南多说，每月有 8700 名数字游民来到麦德林。尽管他们为经济注入了数百万美元，但也导致了租金、住房成本的上涨以及居民的流离失所。原本通常可供当地人租住的公寓现在被租给了游客和数字游民，这场住房短缺给我们的记者路易斯·加略带来了切肤之痛。几个月前，我的房东告诉我，他可以从我在埃尔波夫拉多的公寓里拿到更多的钱。
ago, my landlord told me he could be getting way more money for my apartment in El Poblado. He raised my rent by 100%. And because this was happening all over the neighborhood, it didn't make sense for me to stay in El Poblado. Ana says the same thing happened to one of her good friends. She was pushed out of another upper middle class area, very popular with nomads. Her friend relocated to a working class neighborhood where the rents were also going up, and that probably means her new neighbors will soon be forced to move. So this causes a chain reaction that ends up disleasing people who can no longer afford the neighborhood they have always lived in. This chain reaction has rippled throughout Medellin, especially hurting low income Paisas. The lack of affordable housing options in Medellin has also contributed to a nearly
前几个月，我的房东告诉我，他可以从我在埃尔波夫拉多的公寓里拿到更多的钱。他把我的房租提高了 100%。由于整个社区都在发生这种情况，我继续呆在埃尔波夫拉多已经没有意义了。安娜说，她的一位好朋友也遭遇了同样的事情。她被赶出了另一个深受游民欢迎的上中产阶级社区。她的朋友搬到了一个房租也在上涨的工人阶级社区，这可能意味着她的新邻居很快也会被迫搬走。因此，这引发了一连串的反应，最终导致那些再也负担不起他们一直居住的社区的人们流离失所。这种连锁反应在整个麦德林引起了波澜，尤其伤害了低收入的派萨人（Paisas）。麦德林缺乏负担得起的住房选择，也导致了过去三年无家可归人数激增近
150% rise in homelessness in the last three years. At the WeWork, I asked Hampton, the blonde Texan, what he thought of digital nomads like himself, and their role in Medellin's housing crisis. Interesting question. I think I'm still processing how I feel. I think there's some real legitimate concerns with having such an influx of foreigners. It's hard for me because I'm part of that influx. As we spoke, I could tell Hampton was getting a little nervous. And I get it.
150%。在 WeWork，我问金发德州人汉普顿，他是如何看待像他这样的数字游民及其在麦德林住房危机中所扮演的角色的。有趣的问题。我想我还在消化我的感受。我认为接纳如此大量外国人的涌入确实存在一些合理的担忧。这对我来说很难，因为我是那股涌入潮的一部分。在我们交谈时，我能看出汉普顿有点紧张。我懂的。
Here was a Colombian reporter pointing my microphone at him and asking him, a digital nomad, about how people like him might be making life harder for Medellín's locals. And honestly, I like Hampton. We actually got beers after our interview. I don't think any one digital nomad like Hampton is the problem. The issue is not a single digital nomad. It's like a hundred or a thousand of them. It's nomads swarming Medellin.
这里有一个哥伦比亚记者把麦克风对准他，问他一个数字游民，像他这样的人是如何让麦德林当地人的生活变得更加艰难的。说实话，我挺喜欢汉普顿的。我们在采访后还一起喝了啤酒。我不认为像汉普顿这样的任何一个数字游民是问题所在。问题不在于某个单独的数字游民。就像成百上千个那样。是游民蜂拥而至麦德林。
Back in the 1980s and 90s, when the drug cartels and gangs were fighting in the city, the constant fear in Medellin was that a bomb would go off outside of your home at any moment. The biggest fear in Medellin today is for your landlords to evict you from your home. This is probably the most frustrating part for locals. Things seem to have drifted really far from the promises of the Medellin miracle. Back then, the city sold us an idea that would make Medellin more livable,
早在 20 世纪 80 和 90 年代，当贩毒集团和帮派在城里交火时，麦德林挥之不去的恐惧是随时会有炸弹在你的家门外爆炸。如今在麦德林，最大的恐惧是房东把你从家里赶出去。这可能是对当地人来说最令人沮丧的部分。事情似乎已经偏离了麦德林奇迹的承诺太远了。当时，这座城市向我们推销了一个理念，即让麦德林更宜居，
not for nomads, but for its residents. Coming up, Medellin's growing social problems are spreading up to the city's hillside communities, where things are getting a lot more disturbing. That's after the break. Before we get back to Luis's report, just a quick heads up that this part of the story talks about the sexual exploitation of minors. Up in the valley hills on the west side of Medellin, there's a neighborhood called Comuna 13.
不是为了游民，而是为了它的居民。接下来，麦德林不断加剧的社会问题正蔓延到该市的山坡社区，那里的情况正变得更加令人不安。广告之后继续。在我们回到路易斯报道之前，先给大家提个醒，故事的这部分将谈到未成年人性剥削。在麦德林西侧的山谷山丘上，有一个名为第 13 公社（Comuna 13）的社区。
It's only about five miles from Pablado, which is a very different part of town. During the Pablo Escobar years, Comuna 13 was the epicenter of drug gang violence. It's a place that's often been neglected by city services. It's also been the focus of a lot of social urbanism projects, including those giant, world-famous escalators that we mentioned in the beginning. Zigzagging along the steep hillside, the escalators run in sections totaling nearly 1260 feet. That's three and a half football fields. When they were completed in 2011, those escalators instantly improved the lives of Camuna 13's residents.
它距离波夫拉多只有大约五英里，那是城里一个非常不同的地方。在巴勃罗·埃斯科瓦尔统治的年代，第 13 公社是毒品帮派暴力的中心。这是一个经常被城市服务忽视的地方。它也是许多社会城市主义项目的重点，包括我们一开始提到的那些巨大的世界著名自动扶梯。这些自动扶梯沿着陡峭的山坡呈之字形延伸，分段运行的总长度近 1260 英尺。相当于三个半足球场。当它们于 2011 年完工时，这些自动扶梯瞬间改善了第 13 公社居民的生活。
A commute that used to take more than a half an hour was cut to six minutes or less. These escalators were thought of as a transportation alternative built for elders to carry their groceries to their homes higher up in the hills. Daisy Flores is a community activist from Comuna 13. They were never thought of as a tourist attraction. But today, that's exactly what they are. Right now, if you Google Medellin escalators, you'll see pictures of US and European tourists posing as they ride up into Medellin's poorest neighborhoods.
原本需要半个多小时的通勤时间被缩短到六分钟或更短。这些自动扶梯被认为是为老年人建造的交通替代方案，方便他们将杂货运送到山上的家中。黛西·弗洛雷斯（Daisy Flores）是第 13 公社的社区活动家。它们从来没有被认为是旅游景点。但今天，它们正是如此。现在，如果你在谷歌上搜索麦德林自动扶梯，你会看到美国和欧洲游客摆姿势拍照的照片，他们正乘车前往麦德林最贫困的社区。
Nearly 6,000 visitors pass through Comuna 13 on weekends, gliding up and down the escalators, past walls covered in giant mur up and down the escalators, past walls covered in giant murals. Along those escalators, there are hundreds of souvenir shops selling KRLG trucker hats, Medellin keychains, and a lot of Pablo Escobar paraphernalia. And that's not the only trace left of Pablo Escobar in Comuna 13. In the last 20 years, the local street gangs that once worked for Escobar, patrolling neighborhoods
周末有近 6000 名游客穿过第 13 公社，在自动扶梯上上下滑行，走过绘有巨幅壁画的墙壁上下滑行，走过绘有巨幅壁画的墙壁。沿着这些自动扶梯，有数百家纪念品商店出售 KRLG 卡车司机帽、麦德林钥匙扣以及大量巴勃罗·埃斯科瓦尔的周边商品。这并不是第 13 公社留下的唯一巴勃罗·埃斯科瓦尔的痕迹。在过去的 20 年里，曾经为埃斯科瓦尔效力、在社区巡逻并为他杀人的当地街头帮派，已经演变成有组织犯罪企业，现在他们想要分一杯羹，涉足该市蓬勃发展的旅游业。随着数百万外国人前来参观像第 13 公社这样的地方，他们带着美元和欧元直接走到了帮派的家门口，这正在帮助这些帮派蓬勃发展。恩维加多办公室（La Oficina de Envigado）组织最初是作为埃斯科瓦尔的催收人起家的，但如今已发展成为麦德林最强大、最赚钱的帮派之一。他们接管了深受游客欢迎的夜总会和餐厅。
and doing his killings for him, have morphed into organized crime enterprises that now want a piece of the city's booming tourism industry. As millions of foreigners come to visit places like Camuna 13, they're walking right to the gang's doorstep with their dollars and euros, which are helping those gangs thrive. La Oficina de Envigado organization started as Escobar's debt collectors, but has grown to become one of Medellín's most powerful and profitable gangs today. They have taken over the nightclubs and restaurants popular with visitors.
当游客想要毒品时，帮派就会提供。第 13 公社有一个新的主题公园。它建在一个据信在 20 世纪 90 年代哥伦比亚内战期间许多人失踪并被扔进万人坑的地点上。像恩维加多办公室这样的帮派已经建立了彩弹射击场和步道，游客可以在那里骑全地形车和马。这是一笔非常赚钱的生意。甚至连导游也必须支付勒索费才能进行导游服务。
When tourists want drugs, the gang supplies it. There's a new theme park in Comuna 13. It's built on a site where many people are believed to have been disappeared and thrown into mass graves during Colombia's civil war in the 1990s. Gangs like La Oficina have created paintball fields and trails where tourists ride ATVs and horses. It's a very profitable business. Even tour guides have to pay an extortion fee to be able to give a tour.
帮派已经变得如此有组织，以至于如果你在旅游区提供导游服务或开办企业，他们就会接近你，并请你友好地付款。使这些敲诈勒索和生意对帮派来说格外赚钱的是，这些交易大多是用高价值的美元和欧元进行的。一旦游客看完了所有的壁画并挑选了纪念品，黛西说，这时外国人和帮派之间这种关系中最令人不安的部分才真正显现出来。当旅行结束时，游客会说，还有什么好玩的吗？
The gangs have become so organized that if you give a tour or open a business in the tourist area, they approach you and ask you to kindly make a payment. What makes these shakedowns and businesses extra lucrative for gangs is that most of these transactions are done in the high-value currency of dollars and euros. Once visitors have seen all the murals and picked up their souvenirs, Daisy says that's when the most disturbing part of this relationship between foreigners and gangs really comes to light. When the tour ends, the tourists say, what else is there to do?
暗示着，毒品和女孩在哪里？该市不断增长的性旅游业使未成年人面临越来越大的风险。这些女孩大多来自像第 13 公社这样的低收入社区。麦德林正因为这一点而受到全球关注。一个名为“护照兄弟”（Passport Bros.）的受欢迎的网络运动鼓励美国和欧洲男性
Implying, where are the drugs and the girls? The city's growing sex tourism industry is putting minors increasingly at risk. And most of these girls come from low-income neighborhoods like Comuna 13. Menegeen is getting global attention because of this. A popular online movement called Passport Bros. encourages American and European men
在国外结识所谓的异国风情女孩。带有“护照兄弟麦德林”（#Passport Bros. Menegeen）标签的视频在 TikTok 上拥有数百万的浏览量。在哥伦比亚，性工作是合法的。麦德林活动人士的担忧在于未成年女孩正在成为性贩运的目标，尤其是遭到帮派的贩运。我们已经看到情况如何急剧恶化。伊万·穆尼奥斯（Ivan Muñoz）是麦德林的公共卫生教授兼性贩运专家。他说，未成年人的性剥削在城市中急剧恶化，并且
to meet quote unquote exotic girls abroad. Videos with the hashtag Passport Bros. Menegeen have millions of views on TikTok. Sex work in Colombia is legal. The concern among activists in Medellin is for underage girls who are being sex trafficked, especially by gangs. We have seen how the situation dramatically worsened. Ivan Muñoz is a public health professor and an expert on sex trafficking in Medellin. He says the sexual exploitation of minors has dramatically worsened in the city, and
许多被贩运的女孩来自像第 13 公社这样的低收入社区。有组织犯罪控制了生意的各个方面，伊万说。帮派招募女孩并使用在线平台将她们拉皮条卖给外国人。帮派成员在女孩的家中接她们，然后把她们送到麦德林各地的旅游酒店和爱彼迎（Air BnB）。黛西在第 13 公社的一个青年戏剧项目中工作。她说，她团队里的女孩不断被诱惑从事性工作。她无法与帮派提供的金钱竞争。
a lot of the girls trafficked come from low-income neighborhoods like Comuna 13. Organized crime controls all aspects of the business, Ivan says. The gangs recruit the girls and use online platforms to pimp them out to foreigners. Gang members pick the girls up at their homes and drop them off at tourist hotels and Air BnBs around Medellin. Daisy works in a youth theater program in Comuna 13. She says the girls from her group are constantly lured into sex work. She can't compete with the money the gangs offer them.
对她来说，这一切还有一个更大的后果。这对这座城市来说是个巨大问题，因为孩子们正在辍学。这对整个社区都有影响。被迫从事性工作的年轻女孩可能会永远改变她们的生活方向。而且仅仅因为你想要这项服务…………因为你想要一项服务。这正在使这个问题更加腐化。问题正在恶化。
And for her, there's a bigger consequence to all of this. It's a huge problem for the city because the kids are dropping out of school. There are consequences for the whole community. Young girls being forced into sex work can forever change the direction of their lives. And just because you want this service... ...por el hecho de que tú quieras un servicio. Está corrompiendo mucho más la problemática. The problem is getting worse.
这座城市正在吸引恋童癖者，他们可以在很小的时候就接触到儿童。……从很小的时候就接触到男孩和女孩。在很早的时候。接触儿童和女孩从很早的年龄开始。今年早些时候，当地执法人员在一个豪华酒店房间里发现了两名分别为 12 岁和 13 岁的女孩，她们与一名 36 亿美元的美国人蒂莫西·利文斯顿（Timothy Livingston）在一起。他被捕了，但很快获释，并迅速搭乘航班飞回了美国。这起案件在整个哥伦比亚引发了媒体风暴。网上成千上万的人对警察感到愤怒
The city is attracting pedophiles who can access children at an early age. ...de acceder a niños y niñas desde temprana sea así. at an early age. To access children and girls from early age. Earlier this year, a 36-year-old American named Timothy Livingston was found by local authorities in his luxury hotel room with two girls who were 12 and 13 years old. He was arrested, but soon released, and he quickly caught a flight back to the U.S. The case created a media storm across Colombia. Thousands of people online were furious at the police
放走他，并要求将利文斯顿引渡到哥伦比亚受审。在利文斯顿与未成年女孩被抓的酒店外，抗议者聚集并高呼，美国佬，性游客，我们不欢迎你们这里。美国佬，妓女客，我们不欢迎你们这里。他们举着标语，上面写着“反对性剥削的妇女”，
for letting him get away and demanded that Livingston be extradited to stand trial in Colombia. Outside the hotel where Livingston was caught with the underage girls, Protesters gathered and chanted, gringos, sex tourists, we don't want you here. Gringos, puteros, we don't want you here. They were holding signs that read, women against sexual exploitation,
市长在包庇恋童癖者。利文斯顿一案真正激发了麦德林民众的情绪。多年来，对外国人涌入以及他们推高生活成本、导致无家可归和助长帮派活动的沮丧情绪一直在不断增长。派萨人对此深有感触，但很难弄清楚究竟该对此做些什么。利文斯顿案使这座城市里一直在酝酿的愤怒具象化了。许多哥伦比亚人，尤其是麦德林的本地人，突然变得非常清楚该把愤怒对准哪里——不仅是针对掠夺者，还有市长。
and the city's mayor is covering up pedophiles. The Livingston case really galvanized people in Medellin. Frustration has been growing for years over the influx of foreigners and how they're driving up the cost of living, homelessness and feeding gang activity. Paisas feel it, but it's been hard to figure out exactly what to do about any of it. The Livingston case crystallized outrage that has been simmering in the city. It suddenly became very clear to many Colombians, especially Medellin locals, where to focus their anger, not just on the predators, but also on city leaders.
居民们指责他们背叛了自己的公民。我听过一段时间关于像利文斯顿这样的人的故事，但关于麦德林外国恋童癖者的故事往往被掩盖了。所以我很高兴终于看到了全国范围内的强烈抗议。2008 年，我和一些朋友以及一个表弟去参观了西班牙公园图书馆（Parque Biblioteca España），这是一座刚刚在多明戈萨比奥（Santo Domingo Sabio）开放的全新图书馆，这是一个社区
Residents blame them for turning their backs on their own citizens. I'd been hearing about people like Livingston for a while, but stories about foreign pedophiles in Medellin were often swept under the rug. So I was glad to finally see a national outcry. In 2008, I went with some friends and a cousin to see Parque Biblioteca España, a brand new library that had just opened in Santo Domingo Sabio, a neighborhood
就像第 13 公社一样。我记得乘坐缆车在公社上空滑行，并在山顶的最后一站下车。图书馆就在那里。两栋巨大的黑色建筑，美丽、雄伟、前卫，由一个俯瞰城市的户外阳台相连。前卫，由一个俯瞰城市的户外阳台相连。这座图书馆是法哈多市长的虚荣项目，他领导了麦德林的社会城市主义复兴及其公关活动。他在离任前聘请了一位著名的建筑师，在创纪录的时间内设计并建造了这座图书馆。但在盛大开幕六年之后，图书馆出现了结构问题，并开始
like Comuna 13. I remember gliding above the Comuna on a cable car and getting off at the last stop on the very top of the mountain. And there was the library. Two large black buildings, beautiful, imposing, and edgy, connected with an outdoor balcony overlooking the city. and edgy, connected with an outdoor balcony overlooking the city. The library was a vanity project of Mayor Fajardo, the guy who led Medellín's social urbanism revival and its PR campaign. He hired a famous architect to design and build the library in record time before Fajardo left office. But six years after this grand opening, the library had structural problems and began
分崩离析。它自 2015 年以来一直关闭。在做这个报道时，我经常想起这座图书馆。它是麦德林奇迹变味了的完美隐喻。这是一座宏伟的建筑，有着雄心勃勃的设计，旨在为公社的穷人服务。但所有的宣传消退后不久，图书馆就陷入了失修状态。然后，我最近发现这座城市已经开始修复这座图书馆。这提醒我，还有像黛西和安娜以及无数其他人并没有放弃麦德林。
to fall apart. It's been closed since 2015. While working on this story, I thought about this library a lot. It's the perfect metaphor for what has gone sour with the Medellín Miracle. Here was this magnificent building with an ambitious design meant to serve the poor people in the Comuna. But soon after all the publicity faded, the library fell into a state of disrepair. And then, I recently found out that the city has started fixing the library. It reminded me that there are people like Daisy and Ana and countless others who haven't given up on managing. on Medellin.
至于我，在波夫拉多住了三年之后，我到了再也无法忍受的地步。这里不仅变得非常昂贵，而且社区已经完全变了。一切似乎都迎合了外国人。大多数菜单都是英文的，我觉得我不属于那里。但我知道，如果我搬到麦德林的其他社区，一个对我不那么昂贵的社区，我就会取代其他老居民，而我不想这样。所以我离开了。我离开了麦德林。我没有离开哥伦比亚。我只是搬到了卡利（Cali），那里我有朋友家人，而且音乐氛围浓厚。
As for me, after living in Poblado for the last three years, I reached the point where I couldn't do it anymore. Not only has it become really expensive, but the neighborhood has completely changed. Everything seems catered to foreigners now. Most menus are in English and I feel like I don't belong there. But I knew if I moved to another neighborhood in Medellin, one that was less expensive for me, I would be displacing other longtime residents and I don't want that. So I got out. I left Medellin. I haven't left Colombia. I just moved to Cali where I have friends family, and there's a robust music scene.
我最近回麦德林参观了一次，做了我在那里喜欢做的一切。我坐地铁去市中心买东西，然后去了一个俯瞰麦德林的屋顶上的雷鬼派对。我玩得很开心，这让我很想念那座城市。麦德林需要很多东西。比如专注于经济适用房的新政策以及更强有力的法律来真正保护最脆弱的人。是时候把城市居民放在第一位了。
I recently went back to Medellin for a visit, and I did all the things I enjoy doing there. I took the metro downtown to do some shopping, and I went to a reggaeton party on a rooftop overlooking Medellin. I really enjoyed myself, and it made me miss that city. Medellin needs a lot. Like new policies focused on affordable housing and stronger laws to really protect the most vulnerable. It's time to put the city's residents first.
但现在，我能为麦德林做的最好的事情就是休息一下。因为现在我更好地理解了这个游戏，我不想玩了。本周的 99% Invisible 由路易斯·加略制作，克里斯托弗·约翰逊编辑，希齐克·本·艾哈迈德·法里德混音，音乐由斯旺·雷尔和凯戈·唐纳德创作。尼迪亚·包蒂斯塔进行事实核查。特别感谢本周我们的哥伦比亚协调员克里斯蒂娜·诺里加。
But right now, the best thing I can do for Medellin is to take a break. Because now that I have a better understanding of the game, I don't want to play it. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Luis Gallo, edited by Christopher Johnson, mixed by Hizik bin Ahmad Farid, music by Swan Real and Kego Donald. Fact-checking by Nidia Bautista. Special thanks to this week to our Columbia Fixer, Christina Noriega.
卡米拉·卡萨里和路易斯·费利佩·阿圭拉进行配音。录音室工程师是西蒙·哈拉米略。还要感谢哈尔曼·瓦伦西亚、达里奥·韦尔米雷斯和朱莉安娜·戈麦斯对本报道的帮助。凯茜·图是我们的执行制片人。库尔特·科尔stad 是数字总监，德兰妮·洪是我们的资深编辑。团队的其他成员包括克里斯·佩鲁韦、杰森·德莱昂、埃met特·菲茨杰拉德、加布里埃拉·格拉德尼，
Voiceovers by Camila Casari and Luis Felipe Aguilar. And studio engineer, Simone Jaramillo. Also thanks to Harman Valencia, Dario Vermirez, and Juliana Gomez for their help reporting this story. Cathy Tu is our executive producer. Kurt Kolstad is the digital director, Delaney Hong is our senior editor. The rest of the team includes Chris Perube, Jason DeLeon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Gabriella Gladney,
旁白由卡米拉·卡萨里（Camila Casari）和路易斯·费利佩·阿吉拉尔（Luis Felipe Aguilar）配音。录音室工程师为西蒙娜·哈拉米略（Simone Jaramillo）。同时感谢哈曼·瓦伦西亚（Harman Valencia）、达里奥·维米雷斯（Dario Vermirez）和朱莉安娜·戈麦斯（Juliana Gomez）对本报道采访提供的帮助。凯茜·图（Cathy Tu）是我们的执行制片人。库尔特·科尔stad（Kurt Kolstad）是数字总监，德兰妮·洪（Delaney Hong）是我们的资深编辑。团队的其他成员包括克里斯·佩鲁韦（Chris Perube）、杰森·德莱昂（Jason DeLeon）、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、加布里埃拉·格拉德尼（Gabriella Gladney），
Vivian Leigh, Lasha Madon, Jacob Maldonado-Medina, Nina Potuck, Kelly Prime, Joe Rosenberg, and me, Roman Mars. The 99% of this logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are part of the Stitcher and SiriusXM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. In beautiful Uptown, Oakland, California. You can find us on all the usual social media sites, as well as our brand new Discord server.
Vivian Leigh、Lasha Madon、Jacob Maldonado-Medina、Nina Potuck、Kelly Prime、Joe Rosenberg，以及我，Roman Mars。这个标志的 99% 由 Stefan Lawrence 创作。我们是 Stitcher 和 SiriusXM 播客家族的一员，现在总部位于 Pandora 大楼以北六个街区。位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰美丽的上城。您可以在所有常见的社交媒体网站以及我们的全新 Discord 服务器上找到我们。
There are about 4,500 people talking about architecture. They're talking about the power broker. They're talking about all kinds of fun things. That's where I'm hanging out most of the time. Please join us there. There's a link to that as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
大约有 4,500 人在讨论建筑。他们在讨论《权力掮客》。他们在讨论各种有趣的事情。那是大部分时间我呆的地方。请加入我们。在 99PI.org 上可以找到它的链接以及 99PI 的每一期往期节目。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。